όλα αυτά τα νομάζουμε στόχς ο πάύλος σκεφταί την επόμενη μέρα μετά τους ολυπιακοτο βσοκτώ
πως θα είναι τι θα κάνει τι θέλει να κνει σκέφτεο έχει πολλά πράγματα που
μαρέσι να κάνω ένα από αυτά είναι μο ότι βέσιο νασπίκε το έχω ιδι κάνει
καις ιεταιρείες αλλά το όγανε για α φίλο ο κερδός παρα πολλές φορές σε δημοτικά
σχολαμεσυεγαζία με το υπρογό παιδίας πάντοτε παίρνω τα καλύτερα σχόλία αλλά σπράττο κι εγώ ο
ίδιος πάρα πολύ θετικι νία για αν πάρα πολύ ευνομοσίνει τιχέννιεθούσες να ενέχουν τετρακός αμορά
δώδεκα κατιώ χρονών έντε που συνήθως δεν πορού να κατοιάντοποεί να κάτσον ισυχή καιολοι καθεκηδές
μου λέε στον τέλος ότι πρώτι φράντους βλέπουμε να ντοσοχη υχεια να κούνε αυτό εμένα
μου δείχνει ότι αυτά που τους λέο τους βοηθάνε τους τράβουν την προσοχή το άχιστον
τα ακούσουν και στο και ένα πιδάκι να μπορώ να βοηχίσω για μέναν είναιγγνομοσίναι αυτό
τον πράγμα είναι με κάνε με έθω πολύ χαρούμενο και πολύ περήφανω καιτηλευτά φρό μάστα
στη λάρνακαν θυμάμε ότι τα πιο πολλά παιδιά ξέρις ότανδικασουμεν έρχονται ο κύριο να μου
υπογράψειτε αυτό παραυγαφωτογραφίες και έναν κοριτσάκι εν έχε κύριο κριο πρασόβο κάτι είναι παιισ ότι
θέλεις υχαριστόμα αυτά που είπε σε άλλαξις με τη ζωή αιατούμε το λες καισών ίτετρίχας
ναι κανετε ανταμηβί γιακάτ αντάμεβίπαρόλο βέβαγαείνών πρόγαμμα πολλς φορές α πιντώσουμε να κάνουμε διοτρεις ομιλίες
το γειο προήγίνεται δι μπρεί να ακούσουν πάραποχεή για αμορά αλλά κάθε αφοράν αυτό που
εισπράτο είναιπάρα πολι θετικόν και μαρέσει και ι αυτό είναι κάτι που που θέλω να
κάνω επίσης υπάρχουν σκέψεις γιαθακατημιά ισκιοπλοίας όπου το βλέ πυ έτσι πολύ μεγαλύτερα παράαπλά